thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are currently off the
Record thankfully we have those two very
great guests we got Eric and we also got
Christos
so um I wanted to ask this because um
you I think you mentioned something and
it kind of gave me the idea that a lot
of people might benefit from hearing
um how have you guys overcome addictions
in the past oh cause you know I'm
addicted to a lot of [ __ ] well you
mentioned that you were smoking for like
how many years 20
five no so I'm 38 now and then I started
smoking at like 12 or 13. and you cold
turkey quit it just done yeah how did
you do that that was pretty hard because
it was um I've been wanting to quit
when I like for the past two years and
at the time uh the person I was with we
both were trying to quit but also it's
not good because if you're both addicted
and you're both fighting because you're
addicted too you causing arguments
because you're just like man I need a
cigarette now look what you made me do
[ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta go
you know like
so so uh that was a tough one yeah but I
do remember
um so I used to do these [ __ ] karate
boot camp Retreats right where my karate
club would um get some you know you know
they would rent out space at a
university they'll rent out a dorm they
would house us feed us so all you got to
do is just focus on [ __ ] training so
um it's like almost a week long
so I was like this might be the perfect
time for me where I can't be smoking
because I'm it's gonna make my life
harder trying to do [ __ ] Karate kicks
and [ __ ] while I have a cigarette
dangling off of my mouth you know so I
said all right I'm just gonna throw this
pack away and and this rope like let's
just cold turkey it and then after the
end of it because the first day
um being a smoking like athlete right
it's there's a lot of there's actually a
lot of people that are doing like in in
UFC there's like
like Fighters that'll just like beat the
[ __ ] out of somebody and just go
and then they can still do it yeah but
for me
I think like I I was really feeling it
like I just like I was like this is my
last pack so I'm just gonna go ham and I
just went ham right the next day
I couldn't even [ __ ] like dude like
there were senior citizens Passing Me Up
On The Run and I was like dude what the
[ __ ] I shouldn't be this bad my stamina
is so horrible and I always that was
always my thing is like I'm like like if
I'm sparring or whatever I'm just so
tired and so I started feeling the
negative effects of it and telling my
head for the first time like this is why
smoking sucks like you you can't [ __ ]
run like a grandpa you can't fight and
stay like whatever and then I kept
reminding myself it sucks it sucks
because I kept telling myself I love a
cigarette and coffee I love a [ __ ]
after a meal just go hit you know
and then eventually at the end of it all
I was like I don't [ __ ] need this
[ __ ] man but for a whole month straight
I was like but what if
what if I could get just one you know
yeah or like I would be like maybe I
could call my friends up and we could go
get some uh we could do some hookah ah
yeah or like you know it's like I'd find
clever ways to get nicotine right but I
didn't do any of it because I was like
nah just [ __ ] stop and then after
that point it got easier and easier and
now I can't even stand the smell of it
like if someone's smoking around me I'm
like there's children what the [ __ ] what
up yeah you completely changed
so you haven't smoked one since the
karate theme no no I had to say I had a
cigar like a year ago that's different
though yeah you're not really inhaling
you're not inhaling yeah flavor yeah so
how many years has that been I think
that's 2019 maybe 2020 yeah so I think
it was 2019 20 21 22. yeah good for you
oh July is actually when I ended so it's
been a four four years four years
foreign
I've done every jug in the world and
this is the hardest thing that was that
I thought I had to quit like it was the
hardest thing so now knowing knowing
that you can do that is that something
that now you you understand you have a
you have a muscle for discipline that's
like that's the hard that was the
hardest thing yeah so you can put that
towards other like in-depth yeah like
right now
um me and my girl were doing caffeine so
we're on month four with like no
caffeine okay that was [ __ ] hard yeah
that is really hard yeah and I've done
no sugar before too and I think that was
the hardest that was harder than
caffeine for me sugars and a lot of food
yeah that's why because you have to read
everything what do you what makes you
pick like uh I'm gonna take out sugar or
take out caffeine or like
I'll probably like one day you know I
just read a lot of [ __ ] or like watch
something and then I go hey this might
be the reason why I have insomnia or
like I'll see a thing about how sugar is
in all of our foods and it [ __ ] with
our hormones or whatever and I'm like so
what is it like without it then so I get
curious and then I just want to see what
it's like cigarettes was always like I
don't like this feeling of addiction and
I don't like this feeling of like
um when I especially when I was doing
martial arts with you guys like I was
feeling so tired and I'm like I
shouldn't feel this tired at my age yeah
yeah I remember when you cut like when
you stopped smoking cigarettes cold
turkey I just was like man I don't know
like in my head I was like I don't know
that's a good idea but you [ __ ] did
it dude and I was like wow I was very
impressed because that's so hard because
growing up my dad was a smoker my whole
family is a bunch of smoke it's hard and
I see my dad every stage in his life try
to stop smoking until he had a stroke
maybe about like two three years ago and
that's when he actually actually stop
smoking cigarettes he had like he was
smoking and he was driving and then he
had a stroke while he was right oh crazy
right that's [ __ ] crazy did he crash
no he pulled over to the side and he was
like [ __ ] up but he was like he got
lucky you know he was one of those
things yeah the longest time I'll take
something like that for them to stop so
when I heard you doing that I was like
damn bro good for you because the
longest time I quit before that was in
my mid-20s or something like that
um and it was almost two years yeah and
that was the only time pretty solid too
yeah pretty solid run but before yeah
it's crazy I don't know it's just one of
those things it's always been there
since I was like 12 13. and it's always
going to be right and I and I got myself
addicted because like I was so curious
like I would be like what is that like
you know everyone's doing it but then we
can't do it why yeah and then so I
started picking up cigarette butts on
the ground lighting it and puffing it
because I just wanted to know what that
was like yeah and then like I would be
like age dad's a smoker like can I get
one and then so like me and my friends
would like steal cigarettes from their
like you know from their parents and
[ __ ] and we'd go in the backyard and try
to smoke it and we're like we don't know
what we're doing you know and then
teenagers would be like that's not how
you inhale you inhale like this yeah and
I had I [ __ ] up my lungs and whatever
but like you're becoming a smoker the
process is you really gotta try like you
really Gotta Fight to enjoy it and it
[ __ ] sucks it's like beer yeah
because the kid like you don't like beer
yeah you don't drink beer and go this is
delicious you're just like I have to
keep liking this you're playing beer
pong and that's the thing of like okay
now I can go for a cold beer but what
does that even mean nothing you know
what I'm saying don't taste train
yourself to like it yeah and yeah but I
don't know right now I think it's like
caffeine but now I just like
experimenting because I'm I just want to
know what I would feel like what my
normal is if I didn't
do this routine yeah that's right yeah
because I'm just really interested like
now I'm like what if we try to live as
close to our ancestors as possible it's
hard to do because we live indoors
climate controlled
processed foods all this stuff yeah but
I'm like what if we lived in a hut
and then we ate fresh fish and things
that we picked every day
that's gonna cost a lot to recreate that
right or you just gotta like throw it
all away and go into the jungle and do
it I've seen videos of people doing that
like like turning these caves into like
homes like hold to YouTube genre
oh I love watching those stuff bro hell
yeah but I'm so curious like what would
what would it do because like when I
changed my diet and do all these things
my Eczema cleared up I've been living
with it all my life right yeah every
time yeah eczema yeah yeah all of my
arms but when I when I when I uh changed
my diet and all these things I was like
this [ __ ] is I didn't know it was this
easy I thought I needed pills and things
to fix all this stuff so I'm like what
other things can I just fix naturally
right interesting that's dope yo I did
that with uh like I tried vegan I
thought that would be impossible
especially being a Puerto Rican in
Dominican like rice and chicken is that
that's you know but uh it's actually not
that hard
rice and bananas yeah rice and bananas
with beans you could do that but then
and then also you know with Your Greens
too you know it's how you season it how
you you know or like cooking your
broccoli and frying it like is there or
cauliflower you know they're changing
each other like your fried cauliflower
buffalo and all that stuff like there's
how do you feel any difference when you
change it for sure yeah I honestly I
felt like I was like oh damn and
honestly okay I was only vegan for like
four months but it was it was still
enough for me to go there's enough of a
change I can do it yeah I can do it and
then I I fell into the like wow I feel
so much better after I eat I'm like I
could run a mile right now you know what
I mean like it really does feel that way
like when they when vegans do because I
used to get so annoyed when I would eat
like you know at a round of being around
a vegan's house where they cook and then
they're like you know what you just ate
yeah
you know what I'm saying yeah it wasn't
me yeah the whole Burgers like that's a
flower
you're like how did you do it tastes
just like it don't it so it's a whole
thing I got I got into it whenever I
started eating I was like damn this
makes sense it's like you feel you feel
good good you feel yeah you know because
meat has so much like it's really hard
for your body to break that down so when
you're just eating you know you're just
like I'm about to tear up this [ __ ]
brisket oh they said that you're feeling
like dead like this because your body
don't even know how to break that [ __ ]
down you know I like that yeah I like
that [ __ ] though we like that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this is the best thing though so
I'm I'm the exact opposite so I was like
I was raised in this cult right and part
of the cult we had to be vegans for a
long time and then so the first thing I
had when I got out of like I I broke
free from the cult was I had chicken
wings but I I do a lot of like Ultra
endurance type of like cycling races and
I've for me I recover faster with a
little bit of meat and everything's in
Balance right but if I have the meat
like meat Foods a clean meat of course
and a good balance of vegetables and
stuff I recover faster but everybody I
think is different I learned ultimately
it's just balance yeah you know what I'm
saying like you you don't it don't
matter if you want to be be completely
vegan or if you want to be completely on
the on the other side where you're
eating what's that liver king cat like
you know what I'm saying you can either
be on there
and sexual Tendencies yeah
yeah that guy's insane he's literally
turning into raw meat like he's he
already is [ __ ] and he's like oh I don't
take any steroids yeah yeah that's a
whole other thing but I'm saying you can
either be all over there or all over
here or in the middle you know what I'm
saying like it's not it's not going to
kill you to eat meat and it's also not
gonna kill you to just not eat meat yeah
balance it out you know can't have too
much anything anybody have any other uh
habits that they had to break or
anything that was man well for for me I
think I developed this really weird like
binge eating issue like when I was like
fighting and stuff because I would there
was no education on how to like wake up
properly so anytime we'd have
competitions we would just like starve
ourselves do all the worst kinds of
weigh-in right yeah to weigh in on a
certain day and just like it was just
the worst way to go about it you know
and like I would lose like 15 pounds in
like a week and a half wow you know and
then throughout the whole time I'm just
like obsessing over food I'm gonna lose
15 and a half pounds don't do it that
way I promise you don't do it that and
like uh because it is a trash bag yeah
he knows about that no but uh and I just
created like it was more mental than
anything like I built up
other Foods in my head to be like the
sole focus of everything that I want to
do like I mean like good good food bad
food or you mean not even
food stress eating whatever the case may
be so then like I would just I would
binge eat like crazy you know and then
just feel like [ __ ] the next day and
then just continue to do it over and
over and over again and I like I
developed this really bad habit of like
not eating throughout the day but then
whenever I was hungry I would just eat
like all the water like really bad not
just like bad foods but like fast food
and just like indulge and then my mind
would always be just like centered
around eating these kinds of foods
constantly so I just developed this
really weird habit over time and I just
didn't like how my body was looking how
I was feeling so then that kind of I had
to like rewire everything I had to
rewire how I approach food how I looked
at food so it took a lot more education
for me and obviously I'm in that Fitness
field so I had to really deep dive and a
lot of the clients I was dealing with
were going through the same freaking
issues so then it allowed me to kind of
pull back my lens and really study it
and realize how to create that balance
right because you would hear all these
things like this is bad for you this is
good especially in the nutrition space
you know depending on who you talk to
everything is terrible for you
everything's gonna give you cancer
everything's gonna make you fat so then
I was like I gotta figure this out
myself you know and through that process
I was able to realize just like
everything else we all know we need to
be eating you know and I just it allowed
me to
look at food in a more objective way and
then through there I was like okay I
think I was able to fix this issue that
I had of just binging all the time and
have a stable weight and not just be
yo-yoing like 20 to 15 pounds depending
on the season of when I was training or
not so man like through that process of
just education for me that allowed me to
kind of fix those issues and a lot of
discipline too but for me the biggest
chunk the biggest move for me was just
the education part but what I realized
like getting into more and more things
is if you just dollar cost average your
life
that's literally the key right like baby
snip everything yeah investments just do
that you don't have to buy [ __ ] 10
Bitcoin at once or 10 10 100 000
whatever [ __ ] stocks at once you
little e dollar cost average Investments
you want to get smarter just read 10
pages a day yeah you don't got to cram
five books in one month and then don't
read for five years you know Fitness you
don't gotta [ __ ] go run 10 miles and
now you're [ __ ] burnt the [ __ ] out
like literally the the key to life is
just everything that you're supposed to
do to like your mind your spirit
whatever your body you just need to go
you don't got to go crazy like
anti-carbs or whatever it's just dollar
cost average everything yeah but what if
none of that excites you that's the
problem but nobody wants to hear that
though yeah no one wants to know me no
one wants a quick fix exactly that's the
thing
on it yesterday yeah yeah and so much of
that is based on like their feeling of
like the day right so like they might be
good Monday through Thursday and then
Friday they're like I had a really rough
day and then that causes them to like
throw everything the work that they have
accumulated from Monday Thursday out the
[ __ ] window and then they're just
like I just want to do whatever the [ __ ]
I want I want to eat whatever I want
that's how I feel like when I want a
Cinnabon yeah you know what I mean oh
God yeah I pretty much just good I was
just about to say like a lot of our
decisions are made emotionally like our
emotional yeah there's this one cycle
that's why I invest that's how I invest
too nft worlds
uh there's this one psychologist his
name is Gabor mate and his theory is
that a lot of
um a lot of addiction stem from trauma
and Trauma also creates a lot of
emotional response to things so I I
can't speak for for all addictions but
there are certain addictions out there
that you could clearly look back and be
like why am I doing this like I was
addicted to work like I'd be a
workaholic avoiding my family odd stuff
to just work work work work and I
started realizing that's how I was
raised my dad he would work 60 70 hours
a week to make ends meet so I would look
at my dad as a model of success but for
me to be like my dad I got to answer
work 70 hours a week and only see my
kids on the weekends type of thing right
and he he unintentionally did because he
want he needed to support the family I
didn't need to do that in the position I
was at because I was doing okay right
but like I was looking back at them like
why am I such a workaholic why do I feel
guilty when I want to take a nap why do
I feel guilty I want to go when I want
to do a vacation and I look back I was
like oh it's just how how this
conditioning this trauma that had in the
past type of thing so I don't know
that's just kind of like an interesting
like kind of like thought process of
like why do we do certain things that's
true because certain things that aren't
addict uh like so like let's say crack
is highly addictive right but like
gambling shouldn't be but it is right
because it's not a chemical reaction
that you're taking anything like it has
a serotonin hit it it is yeah but it's
just the hope of winning or whatever it
is the hope that was uh that was me with
uh with women really heavy yeah just
because I would just that's the
addiction you can't kick hell yeah well
this guy is not well yeah but it was
just my dog my eyebrow the Opera well a
moment where it's kind of like you know
uh you know it's a problem when like
your your entire day is just like
invested in just like who can I hit up
and try to you know score for the night
or situate or like or like being on
dating apps in this talking to strangers
in this doing have these crazy
conversations you get to these things or
just like you're just trying to get off
you know me and after you come you just
have that grace period of chillness and
then two hours later you're hitting up
another do it again yeah do it again
yeah it's like and I and I realized yo
like I was realizing that uh like how am
I how how life was going for me when
when I'm in that pocket when I'm in that
phase where I'm just like dark this in
my apartment not leaving I'm just kind
of like just doing my my own little
thing you know what I'm saying like and
so I realized that nothing was really
going right you know I mean like if just
in life just things are just kind of
just going wrong and I realized on the
other side of it where I'm like doing
things that are like you know more
beneficial to me or making me feel happy
or going out and like going out training
with y'all or like dancing on the stairs
life is going well and I'm getting I'm
getting opportunities and things are
happening I'm like oh snap I had to
really think about like oh I see how
because then you test it because then
you go all right well let me see if life
is going good let me go back to getting
down you know what I'm saying and and
seeing what's up and then when I
realized I was like oh shit's hidden
hitting the fan again I'm like okay I'm
recognizing the pattern I'm putting a
lot of energy towards and stuff that
doesn't even matter you know and it's
just for a quick little fix or and then
I would even it would get to the point
where like I would like reward myself I
was like if uh if if I just like made a
video that went crazy viral I would just
be like I'm like [ __ ] like let me hit up
a shorty you know what I'm saying like
or I hit up or or like or even something
that's like a you know small
achievements or whatever it is it's just
like you get that that that
testosterone feel of like I'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I need to conquer you
know what I mean and um I I what would
help me break that was uh moving back
home and then getting back into dancing
because the amount of like work and
dedication it takes to like get these
dancing moves like I'll break dancing
for absence
low-key right yeah it takes a lot penis
it basically like it got me to like um
get those endorphins going that same
like because when I hit windmills for
the first time yo like literally an out
of body experience you can't explain it
yeah unless you do it I'm gonna do this
all day yeah it was almost yeah it was
just like each windmill was like an
orgasm so like like a woman you're like
coming eight times you just get back up
you're just like yo
yeah and so that that was something that
I was able to like you know and now it
gives me even even more confidence you
know going to these clubs and knowing
that like I know what I could do I know
how I can get down and like now I'm
getting more attention right become
dancing and doing all these things but
at the same time it's like I'm I'm cool
with how I feel and I know what I know
what that I know what that journey is
going to be like I know what's gonna
like yeah that'll be hella cool the
perfect scenario like yeah me shorty
same night just now then it's like well
[ __ ] I just I messed up the the the wave
that I've already like created you know
what I'm saying that's some beautiful
self-awareness I know that's true it's
shifting because like we were like for
as kids we're taught to do things to
impress other people yeah but now you're
doing things to impress yourself yes yo
for real yeah it took this was this was
the longest because you what I realized
was that out of the when I moved out
here in 2013 I was I got into a
relationship up and then that didn't
work out got into another relationship
like within like six months I was
getting into new relationships so like
seven out of the you know five out of
the seven years I were invested into
relationships and I didn't like I was
like I didn't move out here for that you
know what I mean and when I'm you know
when I'm in a relationship you want to
be the best boyfriend ever you know
you're going to be the best for this
person but like when now I've been
single for two years and that's almost
like me being sober like it's the
longest I've ever been single ever like
since like high school you know so like
Within These two years I'm learning all
these things about myself and literally
having to become obsessed with myself to
just like okay let me you know go to the
movies by myself or let me go train let
me go let me do some things instead of
feeling like let me hit up a shorty just
investing in yourself yeah because some
people they learn dance to get [ __ ] you
learn dance to get away from [ __ ]
windmill away from the vagina
[Music]